to present the music awards for the Best
Original dramatic score and the best
scoring adaptation and original song
score will you permit me just one
personal note as I think everybody who's
watching here in the theater and
everybody at home knows that man I'm a
song and dance man so you know what a
complete total gasp it is for me to
introduce miss Betty Grable and mr. dick
Haynes
it's really a joy to have a chance at
last to acknowledge the debt the
performers Oh two musicians now the
remarkable part of the of their
contribution is that it's a subtle as a
violin as and as demanding as a trumpet
the nominees for the best original
dramatic score are John Barry for Mary
Queen of Scots
Richard Rodney Bennett for Nicholas and
Alexandra Isaac Hayes for shaft
Jerry fielding for Straw Dogs Michel
Legrand for summer of 42 and the winner
is the winner is Michel Legrand
I just gotta say a few words that I'm
very proud forest I'm very happy I want
to thank the producer of the picture who
is there tonight which I roster dr.
Stangel so the mother is directed of
Milligan and if someone to think you
know many people that we don't thank
very often or not enough often to me
which are all the musicians or the
marvelous musicians that you have in
California thanks all of you